need some new games to play this holiday  we've got plenty of recommendations  around here and so do customers at  gamestop I'm Tony and this is your  festive gamespot news update gamestop  surveyed its power up rewards members to  peg the most anticipated games of the  season no surprise Final Fantasy 15 took  the top spot in second place was  battlefield one third was Pokemon Sun  and Moon fourth was called duty infinite  warfare and fifth was Skyrim special  edition gamestop called out some other  titles like Gears of War for and  watchdogs to but didn't say where they  landed on the list other surveys like  one from Nielsen put battlefield and  call of duty at the top of the list too  so it looks like you guys are all about  those shooters this holiday season so  what games are you looking forward to  let us know in the comments and for all  the latest on all of these games you're  already in the right place